[Musique]
aujourd'hui au loft à bastille si vous
connaissez c'est une ancienne écurie en
fait pour parler de philippe sion pour
parler de lumière connecter pour parler
d'ambiance dans la maison phillips m'a
invité merci philips avec beaucoup de
membres de ma communauté
une fois de plus fort si philips pour
présenter effectivement la maison
connectée l'éclairage collecter du côté
de chez philips
donc ça c'est cool au programme
aujourd'hui bien écouter univers
connectés lumière connectés télé
connectée jeux de console présente un
petit peu tout ce qui se passe vous êtes
chez philippe tube surtout un tout
nouveau produit qui est vraiment
intéressant qui est vraiment cool qui
vous permet en gros de créer un système
de télé ambilight dans la mesure où vous
n'avez pas une télé en bilingue voilà en
tout cas plutôt cool c'est un
répartiteur hdmi je vous emmène dedans
on regarde ça ensemble on se plonge dans
l'ambiance de la lumière philippe thieuw
et vous allez par an d'écart n'est
plutôt pas mal
[Musique]
voilà ici dans mon appartement bastille
or c'est pas vraiment mon appartement je
n'avais pas réellement ici c'est un
appartement qui était mis en place
spécialement par philips pour pouvoir
montrer un peu ce qu'ils sont capables
de faire ce qu'ils peuvent faire les
différentes technologies et ça c'est
plutôt coup alors je vous fais un peu un
petit tour là vous allez on est derrière
vous vous rendez pas compte des espèces
de grands mots tout est fermé
tout le monde est en train de jouer il
ya une grande partie de mario party les
yeux pour l'instant je profite de ce
moment un peu plus calme ici pour vous
montrer un peu ce qu'on est capable
d'apporter tiflis et des chaussures
hypra intéressante vous êtes déjà par
les réductions sur la chaîne si vous le
savez nous on parle régulièrement
j'ai mon studio à clermont j'ai mon
appartement chez moi qui aie il va y
avoir tout le studio à paris aussi fille
à plein tube vraiment intéressantes à
faire traiter de chez philips ou les
jeunes montrent un peu différent techno
les différentes ambiances on va
s'immerger dedans je vais vous montrer à
la fin le nouveau produit croyez moi est
vraiment intéressant pour pouvoir créer
de votre télé qui n'est pas à philippe
s'en faire une mobile ait vraiment
intéressant regardez comme c'est mignon
en fait pas vraiment mon petit bureau
séparément mon macbook moi j'ai un
macbook pro mais j'ai mis un peu les
ambiances à ce que je réalise en sachet
dans le studio sais pas si vous voyez si
vous reconnaissez un petit peu là
l'abricot que je peux ramener de la
maison l'idée ici c'est de vous montrer
un set up de gaming vous jouez sur votre
ordinateur
et bien vous allez pouvoir retrouver une
variation au niveau de vos yoplait ici
pour vous dire vraiment vous immerger
davantage lorsque vous allez jouer pour
venir apporter plus de lumière autour de
votre parti en tout cas de gaming ou de
travail donc ça c'est vachement cool
alors bon ici on nous envoie un petit
peu les prix se connectaient râler c'est
vraiment une thématique prix se
connecter
vous y retrouvez le pont philips ça je
pense que vous devez connaître c'est la
base les différents interlocuteurs lire
ça c'est vachement intéressant parce
qu'en fait là dedans et bien vous n'avez
pas de piles c'est uniquement l'action
mécanique qui va créer de l'énergie
cinétique et qui va vous paraître
fectivement d'allumer vous avez celui-là
bon ça je vous ai déjà montré il ya ce
nouveau petit bouton qui vachement cool
vous appuyez on off tap
regardez pouvait mettre dans votre poche
partir vous voulez que ça c'est plutôt
cool ici interrupteur quatre boutons qui
est développé par une boîte française
naudon french tech plutôt cool
pilar le capteur de présence alors là il
vachement intéressant capteur de
présence capteurs de température s'est
promis de régler vachement de choses
donc ça c'est vraiment intéressante à
vous avez tout l'écosystème un petit peu
je dirais connectique et l'a ensuite sur
l'écosystème en poule avec les notamment
les nouvelles ampoules à filament je
vais les mettre dans studio
prochainement sans jamais récupéré vous
allez voir c'est vachement sympa tableau
radicaux ont fait ça c'est vraiment cool
on retrouvera bientôt bientôt celui-là
take it easy le tableau messieurs greu
avec philip sion c'est vraiment cool et
l'idée ici c'est qu'en fait quand vous
allez à votre éclairage qui va changer
en cours sur de la musique quel que soit
votre éclairage vous ayez une yugo que
vous ayez quoique ce soit même votre la
faune ici tout est fait lips ue si vous
mettez la musique ça bouge c'est sympa
et ça c'est une nouveauté qui va sortir
l'année prochaine
malesza ça je sais pas si vous
connaissez puis pas si ça vous parle en
fait c'est une lampe qui est imprimé
c'est une nouveauté qui va arriver en
2020 vous irez sur le site de philips
you vous allez pouvoir choisir le modèle
que vous voulez et ils vont imprimer
votre lampe directement à partir de
céder parce qu'effectivement phillips a
créé le compact distance une
vieillissante il ya longtemps et or
utilisent les vieux cd pour faire une
banque qui du coup ont recyclé qui est
recyclable et qui vachement sympa et qui
reste dans l'écosystème philippe thieuw
donc ça c'est vraiment cool
là c'est la partie télé bon ambilight
que ceux déjà présenté l'été l'ambilight
je sais pas si ça vous pas à la regarde
et vous avez tous les éclairages ici là
tout le rétro éclairage qui vient vous
rendre directement ce que vous avez sur
votre écran vous retrouver sur le côté
je vous invite à aller voir ma vidéo
pour voir tout ça qui va être en plus
synchronisable avec volante kelly psiu
que vous allez pouvoir retrouver ici
donc une fois de plus grosse ambiance
avec le plafonnier avec tout ça donc ça
votre vraiment l'ambiance un peu globale
et quand on va chercher derrière card et
vous avez la salle tout le monde joue
juste la up
regardez moi le spectacle ça va ça se
passe bien
ouais c'est pas mal j'en fais tu ici eh
bien vous avez un nouveauté qui
planquaient en bas on le voit là juste
là là ça c'est la nouveauté c'est un
boîtier hdmi vous allez pouvoir brancher
votre télé de danse et pourra brancher
votre console est si douce et une
nintendo switch vous allez pouvoir
brancher un lecteur dvd tout ce que vous
voulez pour pouvoir faire de votre télé
une télé ambilight alors l'idée c'est
derrière vous pouvez poser vos la strip
imaginer derrière la la la la
tout le tour ça vous prend en tout cas
tout le système que vous avez ici avec
votre thé l'ambilight devrait pouvoir
retrouver sur une télé qui n'est pas du
tout ambilight que ce soit une télé
philippe ou pas et ça c'est vraiment
cool et vous allez pouvoir l'intégrer
ensuite avec les différents types
d'éclairages que vous avez tous les
côtés ce soit un plafonnier tout ce que
vous voulez et vraiment avoir une
ambiance comment vous dire que ça fait
hip hop une ambiance qui popent enfin
une ambiance qui est vraiment cool qui
va s'adapter du coup à ce que vous allez
faire regarde un film du foot joue un
jeu tout ce que vous voulez donc ça
c'est vraiment chouette
et c'est quand même très l'as tu as i
heureusement prélat merci ça va tu
gagnes tu perds je perds je connais pour
l'instant c'est pas fini encore les
babines et j'aimerais ça va dit on s'en
va et on se faire un nom à talence pas
présent non pas du tout je dois essayer
d'augmenter
ouais ouais ça va mais en fait si vous
vraiment les vainqueurs quoi vous êtes
en train de tartiner quoi et toi tu
joues pas au total dit j'arrête
si j'étais en train de jouer comme des
heures triche et l'anversois subventions
réglera ça se réglera ça monsieur
[Musique]
donc la nouveauté matos et sa garde et
je vous montre ça va sortir l'année
prochaine c'est tout nouveau
ça s'appelle hdmi cinq box alors le nom
est un petit peu compliqué mais bon
pourquoi pas philips you for tv
c'est ce petit boîtier en fait vous
allez pouvoir brancher tout ce que vous
voulez donc vous allez poser ce petit
boîtier vers votre télé en gros c'est un
répartiteur hdmi vous branchez votre
télé apple tv xbox playstation ce que
vous voulez lecteur dvd si vous en avez
encore un tout ce que vous voulez vous
avez votre alimentation et la sueur
micro usb vous avez branché micro usb
vers usb directement pour ça puisse
fonctionner votre télé l'idée c'est que
lorsque vous avez allumé la télé ça va
l'allumer directement sa envoyer le
signal
donc qu'est ce que vous allez faire avec
ça et bien en fait aux classes est
vachement bien parce que ça vous permet
d'utiliser tout votre système philips ou
tous vos éclairages de votre maison avec
votre télé pour en faire une telle
embellie et après vous avez une
application qui vous permet de gérer
tout ce que vous voulez les clés rate
autant citer donc ça c'est vraiment
intéressant vous avez ici votre appli
vous choisissez de style vidéo musique
jeux vous le voyez on va se mettre vidéo
pardon pour votre regard d un petit
s'agissant des flics ce voulait pouvoir
caler l'intensité du signal
en gros l'idée si vous voulez pas que sa
bouche de tous les côtés quand on
regarde un film voulait un truc un petit
peu d'où vous mettez sur délicats ou
modérée pour que ça bouge mais de façon
pas trop trop violente
si vous faites du gaming a contrario que
vous avez une scène là c'est extrême
savent à tartiner tous les côtés ça va
bouger et après vous réglez peu plus
minorité ici donc moi je me faire un
petit film à la cool détendu le soin jeu
mais comme ça je met plutôt en délicats
je viens bcma luminosité ça va venir
souligner mon film sur les côtés de mon
écran mais sans en faire trop
si a contrario je suis un peu énervé je
me fais un film avec des pôles ce que
vous voulez vous n'importe quel jeu
l'ajout sa tartine je veux que ça
réagisse très très très très rapidement
je ne se soit très lumineux et bien je
pousse ça au maximum
et là je vais être dans une ambiance
beaucoup plus immergé avec beaucoup plus
de lumière ça va être vraiment sympa
regardez dans l'esprit customiser votre
intérieur pimp my maison nous entre un
truc cool
ils ont utilisé le lay strip out dans
son cas c'est vraiment pour l'extérieur
et ils l'ont mis dans un meuble tout
percer sa fac au top le néo c'est pas
mal je pense que vous en pensez dit le
moindre commentaire
au bo
[Rires]
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
m
[Musique]
le plus bel hommage
limite
avec bien entendu des choses ce sera un
très bon sujet sur les figurines et on
n'est pas à 100
[Musique]
voilà pour cette vidéo vous à voir
entrer dans l'univers de fait découvrir
sa musique lui carrément cool premier
rang mondial
une fois ça peut vous intéresser cette
petite boîte hdmi pour pouvoir faire de
re télé une ambiance tout l'écosystème
qui dit tout est ce que vous aimez vous
remarquez tout ça en bois commenté après
on se retrouve dès demain on continue à
parler d'elle sur ce je vous embrasse
il fait des bisous des bisous des bisous